the African promised land from the
window of the high-speed train that
connects Cape Town to Tunis you can see
the wonders of the richest continent on
Earth which is powering the global
economy you immediately passed the best
universities in the world where the
global elite compete to send their
children passing through Zimbabwe the
vast acres of fertile farmland that are
the breadbasket of the southern
hemisphere are breathtaking as you
travel through the Congo the machinery
of the nationalized mining industry
marks the horizon Lagos greets you with
the warmest of welcomes a bustling
metropolis that knows no poverty as you
cross the Sahara Desert you cannot take
your eyes of the best expanse of solar
panels the blanket the terrain
in Tunis you arrived at one of the
busiest border control checkpoints in
the world as thousands of people each
day try to migrate in to Africa for work
and opportunity the contrast of your
journey could not be starker you have
just covered thousands of miles with our
passport colonial borders were long ago
abandoned and the continent is unified
into a shared economic and political
vision all of this is only possible
because Africa is able to control her
resources free from the interference of
the West whose role was to impoverish
and underdeveloped the continent first
through slavery then colonialism and
finally unfair trade practices corrupt
puppet African leaders who siphoned off
wealth in offshore banks and spent
lavishly in European department stores
were deposed and governments made
accountable to the people rejecting
Western development aid meant being free
from the despotic economic control of
the World Bank and International
Monetary Fund no more debt repayments
forced us Tara tea with flooding of
African markets with Western produce
Africa never needed Western pity or
foreign charities being paid to build
wells send blankets will provide malaria
relief donating a tiny fraction of the
money exploited from the continent may
have ease collective Western guilt but
it did nothing to change the fact that
the West was the problem in Africa it
was only by removing the claws that dock
so deep and extracted so much for
centuries that Africa could prosper
memories of a time where millions of
children died each year because of poor
access to food feel like a distant
nightmare monuments to those who lost
their lives crossing the Sahara Desert
or drowning on makeshift boats in the
Mediterranean are the only reminder of
the devastating poverty that plagued the
continent and caused so many to flee
instead Africa offers an escape to those
in the Diaspora trapped in the West
facing racism poverty and criminal
injustice they are invited to complete
the historical circle
and return to the African promised land
you